il va être content de nous mais tu crois
que c'est vraiment aujourd'hui ça fait
ta terriens et les frappes lily là on
n'a pas été très gentil avec lui on est
là car oui écrit bonne fête
il faut la mettre dans les avis ils vont
arriver
bonsoir les enfants bon soit le nours
j'ai l'impression que ce soir nicolas et
pimprenelle d'attendre avec impatience
vos projets patrons y ces chers petits
je descends les voir tout de suite mon
échelle et hop hop hop hop hop hop hop
hop
bonsoir les enfants c'est ma fret
ok bonne surprise je ne le savais pas
oui nous sommes à vous et bonne fête
écoute ça q mon enfant avec ses fleurs
sous la pluie
aujourd'hui c'est la fête à la
grenouille et la grenouille
j'ai mon ami voyons on ne souhaite pas
la fête à la bête
surtout un batracien parce que ce fort
tétouan annonce je continue décidément
si nous n'émettons bonne note
cet enfant deviendra vaut rien et il va
nous en faire voir de toutes les
couleurs l'arc en ciel
alors quand ciel qu'elle fait bien
l'arc en ciel le feu bien et personne ne
lui dit rien ouf c'est fini que bompas
tiennent les fleurs ausubel fle ce
qu'elles sont au repos
quand je suis battu c'est pas tous
regardent sur la table ou le super beau
gâteau tu doit souffler les bougies une
seule fois attention un doublé de voix
bravo on va en coupé en morceaux pour
non et non ce gâteau il est pour toi
tout seul et tu va l'emporter avec toi
tu pourra donner un morceau petit
marchand de sable
c'est vrai merci les enfants ce qu'il va
être content je vais lui emporté
peux tu es bien pressés se fera mais je
veux d'abord on me trouve
vous êtes tellement mignon ce soit revue
[Musique]
banide et nous tue c'est quand m
moss le plat
j'étais jeune on veut qu on y apprenait
[Musique]
à te voilà nounours je te souhaite une
bonne fête fidèle compagnon me reçut pas
trop quelle bonne surprise aux essais
beau gâteau ce pour nous peu je vous en
coupe petit trot on pourrait le goûter
patience gros gourmand on le mangera
tranquillement à la maison
c'est plus sage en route bonne nuit mes
chers petits amis allez vous coucher
à demain
à deux bons amis
[Musique]
oh